Hello freak bitches. This
fights about to go down.
[inaudible] what do you think Eddie?
Bravo initial thoughts. I don't know.
Does Luke Rockhold get the same guy after
getting CalEd by Bisping? It's a hard,
hard one to call. Been a long time
outside the octagon. Jim Norton,
what do you think? You're the host of
UFC uncensored on taking David Branch.
Woo new Yorker goes to the new Yorker,
David Branch moving towards him,
dropping some shots. Luke Rockhold
is got a powerful left kick. Yeah,
strong left kick. And he landed at
a few times to the body already.
It's a legit kick and he
catches you with it way outside.
And Luke Rockhold super hard to take down.
He trains all the time with Daniel
Cormier. [inaudible] and Cain Velasquez.
He's got all these monster
wrestlers over there.
How be you've never got mad off and you
think branch wants to take him down?
He might. He's got a
very good ground game.
He sends a black spinning
sidekick. Kayla finish.
Is that? No,
he got wheel kicked in the head by
[inaudible] Belfort and then he got um,
uh,
Chris Weidman tried to wheel kick him and
he took Weidman to the ground and beat
the fuck out of him. And that was
the beginning of the end right there.
It was crazy cause up until that, it
was like a really competitive fight.
Branches Cirque doing a
good job of circling to his
leftover boy that left kick.
He's not old, but he landed it right
there. Branch is doing a real good job.
Oh he's, he's putting Rockhold
in danger and Rockhold
he teed off on him. Oh my
God. Rockwell is in trouble.
This is a real fight and he's, Oh
my God, he's taking Rockhold down.
That's how you know
Rocco's in big trouble.
I brought you super hard to take
down, should have stayed standing AB,
but he lets him know you can take
them down. God damn, this is legit.
And he just looked over at his
friend and waved and said I'm okay.
Or his coach his corner.
But it didn't look okay.
He got hit with bombs,
man. You never, okay.
When you get hit with those kinds of
bombs, you might not have gone out,
but you're not okay. She's a fucking
ham. I may so much different than boxing.
These two fights.
Highlight it like you do.
You guys barely know who Mike Perry
is, right? Yeah. But meanwhile,
he's so invested in that fight.
Chaos. Right? And this fight,
this is fucking chaos in
so many different ways.
One 18 to one 10, I'm not going to
let's get a room or a fucking weekend.
Adelaide Burj is a very nice lady.
I can't say anything terrible,
but that's where it is.
She's always very pleasant. She
always waves and says hello.
I mean just cause I don't think
I agree with her in boxing. Yeah.
Not mad at lady.
Do judges get removed for poor officiating
to good questions that ever happened?
Well, back in the old days,
the Nevada state athletic commission
wasn't being run very well. Um,
Bob Bennett, the guy who runs it now
as an animal, he's, he's on the ball.
He's really good.
And he's really smart and he's just
a real easy guy to talk to too.
And you know he wants
to commission though.
Right now he's Devonish date at same.
Same. It's the same thing. Yeah, he's,
yeah. He handles all that stuff,
so most likely he'll probably
be looking into that. That's,
do they ever get booted
though? If it's not corruption,
if they literally just think this
guy sucks and making decisions,
do they ever get kicked out? Like
you've fucked up too many times?
It's a good question. I don't
know enough about boxing about,
I know when there's a bad decision
and I know names that I keep hearing,
but it's not like I know a MMA judges
that was a T. that's a disgraceful score.
Disgraceful. I agree. And
has she had an another? Yeah,
they're just terrible decisions in
terms of what I think about the call.
Ooh, look out for the Nissan I,
he's trying to trip branch down.
Luke Rockhold super strong, super strong.
Top game branch might be
fade and had been here. Nope.
Branch still looking at wings, some shots.
One of the things that branch thought
was a big factor in this fight was his
boxing, but he's got to avoid those
kicks. Especially the left one man,
the left one's the big one for Rocco
and he'll do it off the switch. Ooh,
that's a nice bright light kick.
He'll do it off the switch
and he's got a nasty question.
Mark kick is question Mark kick is what
he used to crack Bisping with cause he
hits you with the body shots like
over and over and over again,
and then he gets your reaching.
So he throws one like this to the body
and then at the last minute he whips it
around over the top. He's nasty
with that. Really good with that.
It's like one of his best techniques
that in his left power kick that left
power kick to the body. It's just so good.
He stopped Casa Philipo with
that left body kick as well. Oh,
we went jumping round, kicking. Nice
straight left. He said, no, no, no, no.
He certainly looks like he recovered.
Yeah, he recovered for sure. Oh,
he just clipped David Branch
with a right hook. Look,
Rockhold does not want to go out
like that. Bisping fight. See,
here's the clinch, what you're
talking about. Yeah. See,
it's just way harder to pull off.
This is too much scrambling in MMA
and looking for take downs and stuff.
Look at that. Recruit crock hold, get
in the back, get in the back. Oh shit.
David Branch almost goes down. Oh, Luke
Rockhold on top. Very dangerous on top.
Super strong and branch
is tired as fuck man.
Rockhold looks like a surgeon here.
Branch is doing a good
job at protecting them.
One thing Rockwell has got
to watch out for is his legs.
What branches from the
Henzel Gracie school?
What's his motive and put him up against
the cage. When he's smashing a wall,
they can't move. He wants to just hold
them somewhere. Ooh, look up. Not makeup
dude. What do that shit
[inaudible] yeah, just smash them.
Rockhold came on strong
towards the end of that round.
There's nothing more claustrophobic than
washing that when someone's mushed up
against the cage like that. A
a, it could be a Johnson fight.
That's probably the most claustrophobic
I've ever been watching your fight.
That was one of the worst ones over.
There's an a to smashing a guy
against that fence for sure.
Keeping him there and land in shots and
wearing them out and just smashing them.
It takes you back to
when you're 10 years old.
That's how I got beat up when I was a kid.
Like you're just helpless
in a corner. Dude.
That happened to me when I was 14
that's why I started wrestling.
This guy took me down in the locker room
and he was like gonna punch me in the
head, but he decided not to because it
was so easy for him to take me down.
He just grabbed me in a headlock. I
didn't even know if we were fighting.
Like I didn't know what was going on.
Like we were looking at each other and
he was talking some shit and I wasn't
exactly sure like what we're going to
do and then all of a sudden we were
grabbing each other and he just got me
in a headlock and threw me on the ground
and held me there and could
easily punch my face in.
To this day I owe him a debt of
gratitude. Changed your life.
He did change my life cause he
made me realize like, Oh my God.
And then I had a friend,
my friend Steven Arduino,
he was a wrestler in high school
and I was already doing uh,
martial arts then and I just had no idea
how easy it was for someone to take me
down. And we went outside, we went
outside on the grass and it was like,
I could take you down easy. I was like,
no, you can't. And he's like, boom.
I was like, fuck that. Try again.
Boom. I was like, Oh my God,
I got to start wrestling.
So those two events led me to wrestling
class in high school and I was terrible.
I was probably one of the worst
wrestlers in high school history.
I got one one take down. I
would never take anybody down.
I was always afraid that I was
going to catch a knee in my teeth.
So I would just brawl on dudes that took
down. Oof. They tried to take me down.
That was my game plan. But regular
people, when I'd get in a fight,
I would take them down and I
always felt like I was cheating,
but I didn't care cause you use
wrestling. I go, you know what?
I don't give a fuck if someone
fucks with me. I'm a double leg. Um,
and then I'd get like twister
cyclotron punch their stomach.
I did that to a soccer player. He
was talking shit in school and um,
I took him down. [inaudible] think that
it would be cheating. I thought it was,
I didn't think it was real fighting
back then. So when I saw hoists,
when I saw hoists and nosy
too, I'm like, Oh shit,
you could take dudes down and
fight. That's, that's legit.
He's hurting that leg. By the way.
Rockhold is really hurting that leg.
Bolt guys are hurting the
legs. Rockhold has been landed.
A bunch of hard leg kicks on branch
two. This is a serious fight. No,
that's what I mean. He's been, he's
been hurting branches like, Oh yeah,
but rock holds her to men. This
is a, this is a real fight.
Very good fight. Is it funny now?
Like a fight where two guys take each
other down. It's like totally standard.
Like you had no kids today would
ever think that would be cheating.
Like that's how you fight motherfucker.
If someone takes someone
down like Oh shit,
ground and pound kids know
the moves so I can draw.
Oh you guys I see fight videos.
Just street five videos where someone
takes him down and they tap like that's
like the understood moving now.
That's hilarious. But it, look,
if people can tap in street fights, the
world would be a better place. Yeah.
Because if somebody leaves you alone
after you tap and they let it alone,
like you two guys agree to fight
and then someone taps in there,
the guy respects the tap. That's
good. That will, that opens. Yeah.
I hope it does. I hope
it happens more often.
I guess it all depends on what push your
fight to begin with though. Yeah, sure.
You're not signing the contracts. I've
got fucked your chin. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. Boom.
And what's some of the craziest shit is
girls fighting? Cause it's so primal,
especially when they
don't know how to fight.
And that grabbing hair and
just screaming come off
a law's wailing at each other.
See the thing about Rockhold is he's so
used to this shit cause he's in the gym
with D C and Kane doing this.
So like there's very few guys,
they're going to have the kind of clinch
game that Rockhold is going to have and
the kind of grappling like grinding
skills that Rockhold is going to have
because he's been doing it with
these fucking monsters. Yeah,
I mean Ron was past, he's like,
Oh there's a lot of time left to
full Mount cha not good for branch.
Super bad for branch. Let's see if he
gives up his back and trying to get out.
That's, that's super dangerous.
Don't panic. Let's see if he panics.
He's got to figure out a way to
defend himself. Oh look at this.
He's giving up his back. He's
given us back. Give it up his back.
It's going to handcuff him. Oh, he got
that back. Oh, flat place to base flat.
This is terrible branches
in a world of shit. Dude.
Rockhold does this to
everybody, man. Yeah.
He gets on top of you and he just
smashes you. It's so impressive.
Look at his top-mount. No,
he did it to, um, uh, uh,
the Odo Leo Machida. Oh, Bryson Futura
wheel kicked him in the head. Remember?
Oh, that's right dude.
Ranches at serious trouble.
He's going to flatten them out.
That's a serious mountain man.
That back Mount is out of control.
His Mount and his back Mount or sees his
top game. It's just fucking ferocious.
Oh, branch has done. He's done. Did the,
he's just covering up Dan's
give him a lot of chances here,
but he's taken a fucking bad
beat. Tap, tap, tap, tap,
tap the strikes.
Tap the strikes. Great fight. Fuck
yeah. That was a great fight, dude.
Brock holds top game. Might be
the best in the fucking division.
He might be better than Romero. He
might be better bloodshot, right? Yeah.
He's a black belt under who? I don't
know. I don't know who they're. Um,
it's not, um, Oh, it's an
AKA Dave camera. Rio Cameleo.
How long has he been find out? It's
forever. Was still in AKA? No, I think,
but a lot of guys train with them still.
A lot of guys still go over there.
Yeah, we'll throw it to somebody. That's
a joy. Would you suck on that? No,
I wouldn't. Would you put it in your
mouth? No, I wouldn't. Girls would.
Some girls would. Some girls want
to get pregnant with that. Spit
get you pregnant. I used
to depend on the fighter.
Boom. I got a text message from
Vinny Shoreman fucking Adelaide bird.
Again,
a lot of people are aware that Allie
birds does know the best decisions. Boom,
boom, boom, boom. She's trending.
Jamie knows who's trending.
Would you ever know who's
trending? Never. Not. You never.
Would you ever had any idea
ever who's trending or was that,
would you ever have any idea who's
trending? No. SAS. Jamie. Oh,
that's Justin Bieber's look. Trending.
Trending is, he's still on top.
Can't you try two different ways to like
locally like I've had guys go, dude,
you're trending, but I'm not. It's
like a fucking local, like in Jersey.
I'm trying to compare it to other
Jersey people. Nice. Which is,
how does that work? How do you, how
do you train in Jersey? I don't know.
There's a way to do it location wise.
Like when it gets your hopes up and
utilize all snowing fucking cares.
Luke rock hold put the beat
down. But I'll tell you what man,
David Branch made it a scrap made a scrap
for the beginning till Luke Rockhold
wore on him with that pressure,
that clench and that wrestling too.
I'm telling you man, all
those years with Cain and DC,
I mean you don't get any better wrestling
than that. You don't get any better,
more Savage, big giant dudes
than those two. Think about it.
Olympic class wrestler and the arguably
arguably the greatest UFC heavyweight
ever. Well who puts,
who helps cane like that cause he's
obviously he's heavier than [inaudible].
Not much. Not much. DC walks around
all the time at two 35 to 40.
You know, he'll,
he even said he was feeling kind of
slim like this time after the fight.
You know, we did commentary last
weekend and he said, uh, he was a,
usually he'd be at like two 35 by
now, but uh, he was lighter than that.
I think you'd be like two 15 or
two 20 or something like that.
But he'll get up to two 35 so
he canes two 40 so in there,
in the neighborhood of each other,
like five pounds difference with a
world-class grappling like those two guys
have. They just go on war constantly.
Always a problem though for big guys guys.
Two 50 and above finding training
partners. Sure. Tough jujitsu schools,
man. It's tough. We don't have
very many big guys we got right now
in my class, I think the
biggest guy pro 200 pounds.
It's crazy. What a fight man. Huh?
I'm not crazy Luke Rockhold I'll tell
you dude, when that guy gets people down,
they're not getting up. He has
one of the best fucking top games.
You don't see a lot of tap outs due to
strikes. A lot of people don't do it.
They don't believe in it.
A lot of people have said
that like that's a bitch move.
I don't think it is
even even a little bit.
I think it's a smart move when you're
getting hit and you're getting fucked up
and you know you're not
going to recover, you know,
and the fights over does no need to
take extra shots if you know that you're
done, just tap. But it's seen as a
bitch. They see fighters say this.
Well a lot of people
like George Saint Pierre.
That's one of the things that BJ Penn
was taunting him about how he tapped his
strikes against Matt. When Matt beat him,
Matt beat the shit out of him and clipped
him with a big right hand early gun on
top of him, banged out and then
GSP tapped strikes and BJ was like,
I would never tap the strikes,
but really maybe some of those career
fights he should have. You know,
you got nothing left. Why
not? Yeah, I'm going to get
the more you still can get
out of what is my client.
This is my fight and I'll be there soon.
Okay. That sounds a bit, I don't know.
That's some bad trash. Again, it's a,
it's Bisbing cause he's
saying it's his fight.
I think he feels he should be
fighting for the belt nuts. GSP. Yup.
Yeah. I want to be patient. Like I said,
Oh man. You getting credit for taking
that and, and so I in the first round,
yeah, he was in trouble, dude.
He was in trouble for sure.
That Thai clinch stopped the strikes.
Yep. This, this is what stops everything,
man. His fucking smush game. Look at
that step over Mount may no resistance.
And getting that Mount,
he just overwhelmed.
Branch branches couldn't
keep up that pace. You know,
Luke rock holds, I mean, he's
the reason why he was the champ.
He's fucking world-class
in November,
November Madison square garden.
[inaudible]
wow. He's so, he's telling
GSP to back out. Yeah.
[inaudible].